the story of the horizon franchise is a
lot like a lot a lot there's dense lore
a multitude of important characters and
plenty of earth-shattering revelations
and i mean that last point literally and
while the franchise is only really just
getting started we've had more than
enough happen just across a single game
in its dlc expansion to warrant a story
refresher so whether you played the
original on release in 2017 or you're
just jumping in for forbidden west let's
break down the story so far
the horizon franchise plays out its
grand narrative of tribal politics and
robot dino animal things in the 31st
century in the wake of a cataclysmic
robot apocalypse that has wiped out the
majority of humanity those that have
survived have formed tribes and are
living their lives largely devoid of the
technological advancements of their
predecessors who are widely known as the
old ones horizon zero dawn features four
of these tribes the nora deeply
religious warrior hunters from the south
who worship at the altar of all mother a
mystical mountain the karja who reside
in the bustling cities of the central
deserts and revere the sun god the
osaram a tribe of practically minded
forge men and women and the banuk who
are a mountain dwelling tribe of hunters
and shaman the tribes aren't exactly all
on friendly terms either with the karja
being notorious for raiding their rivals
under the leadership of the mad sun king
jiren
scattered across the stunning
post-apocalyptic landscapes are animal
and dinosaur-like robots known as
machines who for the most part
peacefully co-exist with the tribes
however as the years pass by the
machines have become increasingly more
violent towards humanity as part of a
phenomenon known as the derangement so
begins horizon zero dawn
horizon zero dawn starts with the
franchise's central protagonist eloy as
a cute little baby found alone in the
heart of a sacred nora mountain the
aforementioned all mother poor little
eloy is shunned from the nora tribe for
not having a mother and is subsequently
raised by her surrogate father rost who
is also a nora outcast
fast forward about five or six years and
little eloy stumbles into a cave system
that was once a base of operations for
the old ones it's here where she
discovers a magic little trinket known
as a focus a tiny little earpiece that
shows her visions of the old ones and
vital information about the machines and
the surrounding world she puts it to the
test by saving this unlucky nora lad
from a sticky end at the hands of some
striders which are horse-like machines
stumbling upon the focus piques ayloy's
interest into her own past where she
came from and more importantly who her
mother is she bombards rost with
questions about who she is and he
eventually tells her that the only way
she can learn about her roots is by
winning at the proving a nora tradition
which sees young men and women compete
in trials if she wins she'll be granted
any wish including being reintegrated
into the nora where she can start to
find out more about herself of course
ross tells her that it will take years
of training to be ready for the proving
so better cue a montage
[Music]
as eloy comes of age she makes her way
to the proving with rost who tells her
that she'll never be able to see him
again once she wins at the trials for
your sake
i must go away you will never find me
after their sad farewell ailoy makes her
way into the town of mother's heart
where a pre-proving celebration is
taking place a host of delegates from
the karja tribe are also in town
bringing with them good news the mad sun
king is dead killed at the hands of his
own son avad who wants to apologize you
know for all the murdering and pillaging
his people have been doing over the
years before she hunkers down for the
night eloy strikes up a conversation
with olin a carja tribesman who's also
sporting a focus olin shiftingly excuses
himself before a big brash osseram lad
called erend introduces himself and
invites aeloy to come and hang out with
him in meridian the bustling carjan
metropolis he's a little forward our
errand don't worry he's a good lad
you'll see the next day the proving
kicks off and despite some heinous acts
of sabotage from her competitors aloy
manages to win but just as the winner's
ceremony is coming to a close a tribe of
cultists thugs known as the eclipse
crashed the party bringing down death
and destruction on the young competitors
aloy fights back killing a whole bunch
of the cult and pocketing one of their
focuses in the process
many of the young nora warriors are
killed though and just as ayloy is about
to join them rust swings on by and saves
her before the whole mountaintop is
consumed by a giant fireball taking poor
rost with it r.i.p rust we hardly knew
you ailoy wakes up in the heart of a
mountain sanctuary where she unearths
some unsettling truths about her past
from the eclipse focus namely that she
has a near identical dna match with an
unknown woman that could be her mother
when she speaks to tirsa one of the nora
high matriarchs she's told that the
woman can't be her mother because she
has no mother you were not born of a
woman aloy
the mountain is your mother
tears elaborates on this maddeningly
cryptic message by telling eloy that she
was found in the mountain next to their
goddess the all mother which turns out
to be a great big metallic door but
this isn't a goddess aloy
it's a door the door immediately starts
talking to ailoy like their old mates
but due to some form of corruption she
can't gain access to the secrets behind
it to rid the door of corruption ailoy
plots to follow olin's trail back to
meridian which means that she'll need to
venture outside the borders of the nora
tribe to allow her to leave tears and
the other matriarchs bestow aloy with
the honor of seeker no not that kind of
seeker as a seeker eloy is allowed to
come and go as she pleases to explore
the world beyond the sacred land of the
nora and even the ruins of the old ones
a feat that would normally get you
outcast and with questions to answer and
mysteries to unravel ailoy sets off for
the karja capital just as she's about to
leave though she's attacked by a
corrupter a scorpion-like machine that
is turning other machines totally rabid
aloy makes short work of the abomination
and rifling through the remains finds a
little doodad which is a technical term
that she bolts onto her spear which
allows her to override the machines
ayloid journeys west and catches back up
with her old pal errand who takes her to
olin's house to pick up his trail and
get some answers the trail leads aloy to
a dig site in the desert where olin is
helping the eclipse unearth more
corrupters to wage war and reclaim
meridian from the new sun king you see
it turns out that the eclipse are a
splinter group of the karja led by this
pasty looking lad called helis and they
worship a metal demon known as hades
more on him
it later and they've been blackmailing
poor olin to help them with their
nefarious plans to regain power the
eclipse also want alloy dead because she
looks like the woman that she dna
matched with a trivial fact that came
about because olin found a picture of
the woman at a place called maker's end
before she ventures to make her zen
though ailoy assists errand in
uncovering the details behind who
murdered his sister ursa using her focus
alloy detects foul play at ursus murder
scene i suspect fail play
is my terrible southern accent i'm
really sorry
it turns out the body in the meridian
morgue is not aaron's sister dun dun dun
and after a quick conflab with his
majesty the sun king avad aloy and eren
are sent after an osram terrorist known
as derval who's thought to be behind the
deception the pair tracked down ursus
captors to the mountains in the north
where they discover aaron's sister
shackled and near death after a brief
reunion between brother and sister ursa
succumbs to her wounds in the makeshift
prison the pair discover a plot to blow
up meridian so they hightail it back to
the capital there they find a warehouse
of highly flammable green blaze think
game of thrones is wildfire and foiled
deval's plans to destroy the city only
that's half the plan as ayloy tracks the
terrorists to the throne of the vad
where she foils an assassination attempt
on the king's life and with that little
side adventure sewn up she begins her
journey north to maker's end on route to
maker's end eloy starts to hear a
mysterious voice in her head a voice
that guides her and helps her towards
her goal of infiltrating the facility
that she finds ailoy discovers that
maker's end is actually faro automated
solutions a manufacturing plant designed
to build huge military machines that can
help nations keep the peace the
scientists behind this endeavor are dr
ted farrow and dr elizabeth sobek aloy's
mysterious doppelganger and they've
built these machines with ai so smart
that they can replicate themselves the
catch though is that they need living
matter to be able to replicate which is
the biggest red flag you can think of i
mean why would you build that come on
does the terminator franchise not exist
in this world or what to absolutely no
one's surprised there's a malfunction
with the ai which sends the terrible
sentient robots on the path towards an
all-you-can-eat buffet of planet earth
which ailoy learns is what happened one
thousand years prior after learning
about all this doom and gloom aloy
finally meets the man behind the
mysterious voice who turns out to be a
guy called silence played by the
absolute legend that is lance redick do
you really have no idea how monumental
are the discoveries you just made eloy
and while she's initially hesitant to
team up with him aloy eventually agrees
to work with silence as he seems to have
a lot of the answers that she's
searching for
silence who's keen to uncover more info
surrounding the old ones sends ayloy on
a mission to sneak her way into another
old world ruin she sneaks underneath the
eclipse stronghold of sunfl and enters
the ruin which turns out to be the base
of operations for something known as
project zero dawn but what exactly is
project zero dawn well first the bad
news turns out the old ones knew they
were doomed and never planned to save
themselves from the impending
robopocalypse zero dawn is not a super
weapons program
and it will not save us
nothing will save us
the good news though they instead sought
to set in motion the ability to rebuild
the earth in the post-apocalypse to this
end a team of scientists led by dr sobek
created an ai known as gaia who they
would engineer with the required
knowledge and power to deactivate faro's
all-consuming murderbots and revive the
decimated husk of earth gaia would
create an ecosystem of machines in order
to revive the planet before growing a
new race of humans to populate her
rebuilt world the team broke gaia down
into 9 sub-systems that were all
designed to do different things among
them was apollo a huge directory of all
human history and culture which was
designed to give the new humans a head
start in the old technological rat race
but there was also a program known as
hades one in the same as the metal demon
the eclipse are in league with which it
turns out is a fail-safe software
designed to wipe the slate clean if gaia
was to ever screw everything up deep
within the zero dawn ruins haloy makes
her way into the long vacant office of
dr sobek where she finds the key that
will allow her to bypass the corruption
she encountered at the all mother door
but just as she's about to leave she's
ambushed by helis and his eclipse goons
and knocked unconscious aloya wakes in a
cage in the coliseum-like arena at
sunfall where she is pitted against a
horde of machines and corrupters as a
blood sacrifice just as it looks like
she's got her work cut out for her she's
rescued by silence in a proper fist
pumping the air moment god i love lance
redick
[Applause]
after her near-death experience ailoy
ventures back to the nora tribal lands
where she encounters the eclipsed
soldiers who have already started to
invade ailoy makes it through the
invading troops helping the nora tribe
to fight back in the process before she
gains access to the all mother after
making it through that big metallic door
goddess aeloy discovers that the ruin is
another base of gaia all mother it turns
out is in fact a facility designed to
rebuild and repopulate humanity there
ailoy learns that an unknown signal
triggered hades to kickstart his
doomsday protocol and take complete
control of gaia to stop this gaia
ultimately made the call to
self-destruct her core ai and in the
process blows up half a mountain and
more importantly terminates all the
ongoing terraforming processes on planet
earth but even more of a bombshell
unless you saw it coming from a mile off
is that eloy is actually a clone of the
good dr sobek gaia's plan for ailoy was
for her to restore her ai programs and
destroy hades only the nora tribe kind
of got in the way of that plan and well
if it weren't for alloy stumbling into
that cave by blind luck none of this
would have happened but maybe that's
just me being cynical
with the weight of all that new
information on her shoulders ailoy heads
north to visit the decimated remains of
gaia and lo and behold there are yet
more bombshells waiting for her to
discover first is the tragic ending of
her new sort of mum dr sobek who eloy
learned sacrificed herself to protect
gaia's location from the plague of
faro's motorbots secondly that ted
farrow who by now is in pole position
for the role of world's greatest [ __ ]
sabotaged the apollo program thus
eradicating all of the key information
designed to teach the next generation of
humans but hey at least he probably got
rid of twitter in the process and nfts
it's like it's like it's been erased
[Music]
erased from existence
and consequently this is the chief
reason why the current crop of humanity
is regressed to tribal societies and
thirdly once ailoy has attained a master
override from gaia's remains which will
delete hades forever she comes face to
face with silence for the last time
turns out that he's the founder of the
eclipse as he's the lad who discovered
the wreck of hades and half the reason
why everyone's in this mess in the first
place damn this game likes to keep
dropping big bombshells why are you
telling me this now
because your success depends on knowing
this
silence isn't entirely a bad egg though
he's figured out what hades ultimate
plan is which he shares with eloy
telling her that the rogue ai is
prepping a signal to revive all of
pharaoh's old murderbots which are lying
dormant under the earth on top of that
helis and the eclipse are preparing to
launch an attack on meridian where they
seek to gain access to the giant spire
tower that is located there a tower that
is perfect for broadcasting haiti's
signal ailoy hightails it back to
meridian to warn anyone and everyone
that matters and with the help of errand
and the sun king of ad she's able to
muster up the support needed to set up
defenses against the incoming army of
eclipse soldiers and corrupted bots
depending on how many side quests you
completed along the way ailoy is joined
by any allies that she has made and with
their help she overcomes and kills helis
before defending meridian from the horde
of deadly machines despite their best
efforts hades is still able to break
through and after nearly being crushed
to death aloy pursues the rotten ai to
the bottom of the spire where she drives
a lance straight into the egotistical
robot ending his nonsense for good
horizon zero dawn comes to a close with
ayloy making a pilgrimage to the final
resting place of her sort of mum dr
sobek where she honors the memory of the
woman who pretty much single-handedly
saved humanity what a top lass but wait
there's one of those sneaky little
post-credit stings that shows that hades
isn't actually dead as we see a glowing
orb of red light rising from his
metallic corpse and flying off into the
horizon to be snared by none other than
our old mate silence who traps the ai in
some kind of lantern
hello old friend
remember me
[Music]
we've still so much to discuss
okay so technically the frozen wild
actually takes place before the final
fight that goes down at meridian at the
end of zero dawn but i've included it
here because if i'd have chatted about
it earlier it would have completely
derailed my recap of the main story of
zero dawn and besides i found it a
little weird that when i returned to
zero dawn right before that final battle
aloy had an opportunity to go and
explore a whole new region and get stuck
into a whole new side adventure despite
knowing about the impending end of the
world but maybe that's just me
anyways the frozen wilds takes ayloy to
the far mountains in the north to a
post-apocalyptic montana and the remains
of the yellowstone national park a place
now known as the cut there ailoy
encounters the banug tribe who are
battling a daemon that hails from a
mountain known as thunder's drum and is
causing machines to go mad after an
unsuccessful attempt to destroy the
daemon the tribe shaman area has
disappeared and with eloy unable to
investigate the disturbance without the
blessing of the shaman she heads off in
pursuit of herrera she eventually finds
aurea in a mountain top satellite
facility which has been transformed into
a banuk shrine and the pair agree to
work together after eloy is able to make
contact with an ai spirit at the banug
revere due to banuk tribal laws before
they can travel to thunder's drum ailoy
must challenge the chieftain arya's
brother aratak and replace him as the
head of the tribe bit of a ballsy move
for an outsider it's a bold strategy
cotton let's see if it pays off for him
long story short aloy beats aratak at
the challenge by gaining his trust when
they are ambushed by frost claws giant
bear-like machines that belch ice and
she has proclaimed chieftain ailoy and
orreya head to thunder's drum and
infiltrate another old world ruin where
they learn the banuk spirit is actually
an ai called sion whose sole
responsibility is to make sure the
yellowstone national park doesn't
explode from you know all the tectonic
activity going on it's also revealed
that the daemon is in fact another
subsystem of gaia known as hephaestus a
subsystem designed solely to build more
machines ailoy and arreya battle through
hephaistus's corruption before arreya
sacrifices herself in order for them to
destroy the facility eloy makes it out
with air attack and cyan reveals to them
that hephaestus is still alive but in
hiding ailoy relinquishes control of the
banuk tribe back to aratak and ventures
back to meridian to crack on with saving
the world but as you know we've already
covered that
and with that bring on horizon forbidden
west thanks so much for watching this
story recap of the horizon franchise i
hope you enjoyed it and are like me
looking forward to seeing where the
story goes next
[Music]